vigneron merci la parole est à monsieur
thierry mariani merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
depuis 1883 les alliances françaises
développent et défendent dans le monde
les valeurs et les ambitions de notre
culture les alliances françaises ce sont
8 116 associations présentes dans 135
pays et elle constitue la première école
de langues de notre langue française
avec près de 560 mille apprenants
aujourd'hui madame la ministre vous le
savez la fondation alliance française
lance une initiative le défi d'un
million d'amis pour l'alliance française
dont je porte à mon veston le symbole il
s'agit tout simplement la de rappeler
l'action que rang de les alliances
françaises au service du rayonnement de
notre pays et je dois dire que comme mon
collègue député les français de
l'étranger alain marsaud à chacun de mes
déplacements je peux constater
l'enthousiasmé des deux ce qui justement
défendre notre langue de chisinau à
chengdu de perth à oulan-bator cher à
mon ami jérôme chartier je vois chaque
fois des équipes dynamique enthousiaste
qui oeuvrent pour défendre notre langue
alors ma question pose dessus porte en
réalité sur l'avenir de ses professeurs
de fle français langue étrangère
madame le ministre en réalité ils
demandent de vous le savez une
reconnaissance quand ils reviennent en
france
il faut savoir que ces profs le plus
souvent sont payés moins de 1000 euros
dans les pays sur des contrats locaux et
il demande simplement une chose est ce
que vous pouvez ou non créer un contrat
un capes pour qu'en réalité ses
professeurs de langues étrangères
puissent voir leur rock leur creux
spécificité reconnu et continuer leur
carrière une va une fois arrivés en
france et d'autre part le diplôme mise
en place par l'alliance française de
paris
le dha elf le diplôme d'aptitude à
l'enseignement du français langue
étrangère
est-ce qu'il peut être reconnu en
réalité ces profs sont démissionnaires
de notre langue française ils sont peu
payés sont là jacques van aubel
c'est ministre de l'éducation nationale
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député mariani merci pour
votre question et pour l'hommage que
vous venez de rendre aux enseignants
français langue étrangère que je partage
absolument car il faut bien le dire
qu'il soit en poste à l'étranger ou
parfois en france puisque cela arrive
ils sont confrontés en effet une
diversité de public et à une diversité
de motivation pour apprendre le français
qui est assez impressionnante et ils
font un travail très précieux la
diversité des motivations c'est aussi
bien le désir d'intégration le projet
professionnel la reprise d'études que
s'agissant par exemple des réfugiés que
nous recevons en france et qui vont
ainsi apprendre le français
une question de survie quasiment donc je
veux à mon tour vraiment leur rendre
hommage et vous rassurer sur le fait que
nous prenons en considération leur
situation particulière même si on peut
toujours améliorer les choses et je suis
prête à y travailler avec vous par
exemple dans le concours
d'enseignement qui leur est proposé à
ces enseignants qui ont exercé à
l'étranger ils peuvent passer par la
voie interne qui va leur permettre de
voir reconnu leur exercice professionnel
à l'étranger dès lors qu'il a duré au
moins trois ans c'est une façon de
mettre en avant les compétences qu'ils
ont pu acquérir dans ses expériences à
l'étranger
deuxième exemple le cap est ce que vous
avez évoquées j'en profite pour dire que
le capes lettres modernes voit son
nombre d'inscrits au concours de cette
année augmenter de 9% c'est une très
bonne nouvelle est bien dans ce cas
parce lettres modernes vous avez une
option qui permet le recrutement
d'enseignants spécialisés dans
l'enseignement du français aux étrangers
enfin dernier mot pour vous dire que la
formation spécialisée de ses enseignants
fle leur permet également d'intervenir
dans des centres de formation publics
donc nous mettons aujourd'hui beaucoup
de choses en oeuvre pour leur faciliter
la tâche
mais je suis prête à travailler pour que
nous allions plus loin merci